au rythme immuable des jours qui thème
l'eau des rivières ses comptes depuis la
nuit des temps sans cela c'est mon ombre
et lumière se partagent tour à tour
l'espagnol a bien tout entière une
lumière des rayons une clarté
celle d'une bonne étoile appelée soleil
qu'ils y seront sans compter et classé
chaleur permettant ainsi à la vie
d'exister le soleil l'astre du jour
l'étoile la plus proche de la planète
terre reste celle que nous connaissons
le mieux aujourd'hui et cela malgré
encore bien des mystères le soleil une
fabuleuse aventure
la fabuleuse aventure du soleil commence
il ya près de cinq milliards d'années
quelque part dans l'univers par l'énorme
contraction d'un immense nuage de gaz
interstellaires une réaction d'une
extrême violence qui fait complètement
fondre l'hydrogène originel le
transformant en étant d'atomes d'hélium
ainsi se constitue le coeur du soleil
source et siège d'une quantité d'énergie
absolument considérable
énergie pour la température avoisine les
15 millions dé devenir une formidable
d'être qui met dix millions d'années
pour s'extraire du noyau du soleil avant
de se dissiper essentiellement en partie
au centre d'un gigantesque système qui
porte son nom
le soleil rêver le mouvement des neuf
planètes qui gravitent autour de lui
quant à l'énergie qu'ils dégagent
celles-ci forment une haie qu'à se faire
une énorme zone d'influencé de 10 voire
15 milliards de km2 d'eau dans laquelle
m
champs magnétiques émis par le soleil à
tort m au cours des éruptions solaires
une formidable quantité d'énergie est
libéré et d'immenses flux de particules
constituant gigantesque finalement
véhiculée par le vent solaire sont assis
injectés dans le vide interplanétaire
mais au fil des millénaires les
productions d'énergie diminue
régulièrement et dans 5 milliards
d'années environ ces réactions
thermonucléaires devrait cesser
définitivement le soleil devenues
géantes rouges dépendra alors tout sur
son passage et sur la version chauffée à
plus de 1000 degrés toute forme de vie
de cadre à des luttes ou soleil se
contractera alors à outrance de plans
même blanche et noire là l'objet noirs
denses et dégénéré avant
heureusement ses astra de qualité ne
sont pas ou peu
le soleil histoire essentiellement
aujourd'hui toujours synonyme de chaleur
les intentionnel la complexité les
domaines
soit parce qu'elles
tous passent ailleurs les autres étoiles
procède dégageant d'une seconde étant
d'énergie cautionnerait la france paris
la ville lumière et sa tour eiffel en
près de cinq ans
cette candide énorme d'énergie dans le
soleil est aussi bien sur les variations
que subit ces émissions ont des
répercussions directes pour notre
planète principal phénomène acceptable
celui des taches solaires qui évolue
période
la voici à la même échelle
la terre puis jupiter une planète géante
la prose du système solaire et à droite
le soleil dont le diamètre de 100 fois
plus grand que celui de la terre le
soleil
il m'a ce gigantesque se trouve à 150
millions de kilomètres de nous et qui
tourne sur lui-même en 25 jours en
moyenne
autre élément comparaison je suis de ces
pages sombres à la taille de la terre
aux pions du soleil les réactions
nucléaires de fusion sont d'une extrême
violence
ce que nous voyons à l'oeil nu et que sa
surface une fine couche de 300
kilomètres d'épaisseur ont appelé
une surface parsemé de taches sombres
qui sont les régions froides avec
environ 4 500 livrés entre les aussi
brillante les plus chaudes avec sept
mille degrés lors de l'activité solaire
maximum caire lieu de 11 ans ces tâches
se regroupant différentes zones très
active devenant les sièges d'éruption
violente et d'envol de filaments
matricule
au dessus de la photo ce faire on
retrouve la chromosphère une zone de
2500 kilomètres d'épaisseur visible
seulement en lumière monochromatique ou
lors des éclipses solaires
puis enfin la couronne une énorme région
interplanétaire extrêmement active dans
laquelle la température tout à fait un
double mission
une zone à la base de laquelle des jets
de matière ionisée qui départ des champs
magnétiques très puissant peut dépasser
100 1000 km de hauteur
c'est de cette couronne que c'est châble
vent solaire infimes particules qui se
propage ensuite dans le milieu
interplanétaire analytes et samsung
de 400 kilomètres par seconde et que
l'on a c'est à travers l'univers le
champ magnétique solaire cebit g pour
l'attraction terrestre est à l'origine
du phénomène appelé aurores boréales
récemment des chercheurs ont démontré
que la période fixe de rauzan entre deux
activités sont au maximum et un cacique
le magnétisme de 22h10 un canyon
renverse la polarité et deux hémisphères
du soleil c'est donc l'évolution au
cours du temps des champs magnétiques du
soleil qui gouverna si l'activité
solaire
il apparaît nation nous assistâmes
énergie qui rayonne jusqu'à nous
l'alimentation électrique des socialites
c'est au début des années 50
la première applications industrielles
utilisant cette énergie abondante et
riza bleu ciel l'énergie reculé grâce à
ses panneaux solaires sera restitué aux
satellites pendant sa traversée la nuit
et ces panneaux sont tentés de
véritables elle n'a pas constitué le
capteur solaire appelées cellules
photovoltaïques aux photos bilal
plus généralement à base de silicium
un produit conçu pour le spatial qui
depuis près de 20 ans a trouvé sur terre
vos applications
alimentation en énergie la maison
entièrement composé pour le solaire ou
une
bachelot expiration les réalisations
quotidienne dans les pays en voie de
développement c'est d'énergie
inépuisable et propre à l'international
à 12
selon lui
donc cela représente 8 bilan thermique
mais 50 millions de temps ajouté m
soit dix mille fois les besoins
hélas cette énergie propre et rigueur
devant par capteurs solaires restent
très chères sont bridées pour cent fois
ce monde à yoann thermique nucléaire et
avait de plus plus pratique effet
utilisé la grande échelle pour
c'est pourquoi elle demeure aujourd'hui
et ne savait neige bien l'autre manière
de convertir cet enfant mais la berge
ces deux-là captées sur une véritable
nappe de miroirs appelé les stadiers
sont atteints il est intéressant de
faire une chaudière à vapeur de type
classique
c'est l'expérience réalisée ici par
seconde
dans le sud la force une expérimentation
conduite
mais là encore si la solution ne
paraître les jantes la réalisation de
tels sentiments mais peut-être un peu
fou
et dans les régions présentant un
autre difficulté le prix les problèmes
de boîte à des centaines voire des
milliers de miroirs
dans lesquels voient dans la balance et
avec une très grande précision
ce refus de d'arizona
énergie diffuse à terre
propres disponibles l'énergie solaire
est à présent thompson
très séduisante restera longtemps encore
une énergie de substitution de bois en
effet là
plus adroits
ces moments
en californie premier aujourd'hui encore
dix fois moins d'énergie que ce temps
d'une centrale nucléaire d'edf
le big bang
une forme d'art est on sûr pas laquelle
il ya 15 milliards d'années
une fantastique libération d'énergie
en essence à l'univers
un monde en perpétuelle expansion un
espace infini
dans lequel des milliards de milliards
de galaxies
aujourd'hui encore
à s'éloignent les unes des autres à des
vitesses vertigineuses
notre galaxie l'agglomération de plus de
100 milliards des toiles dans notre
soleil entre lesquels s'intercale
pierre située à 30 me la manière de son
centre d'escrimé 240 millions d'années
pour faire le tour soit environ une
vingtaine de répulsion seulement depuis
la création de l'univers et cela à une
vitesse qui est pourtant 250 mètres par
seconde dans ce mouvement autour du lac
ci ne serait entraînent avec eux tout
d'un cortège de corps célestes les
publics y sont minuscules poussières
interplanétaires
d'autres thèmes liés d'astéroïdes et
même de sable comme est dans certaines
zones traversées notre système solaire
et plus gros étant de véritables planète
aujourd'hui
nous en connaissons neuf principales
avec dans l'ordre
du soleil mercure vénus la terre mars
jupiter saturne uranus neptune mais
plutôt c'est de ces planètes possèdent
leur propre satellite naturel
la terre et quatre planètes dont saturn
sont entourées d'un homme
politique de planètes des planètes
telluriques ce sont les plus petites
et aussi celles qui sont les plus
proches du soleil ce sont au mercure
vénus la terre
oui 6 mars des corps solides ou sur leur
chemin
les planètes telluriques sont de
formation ancien environ quatre
milliards et demi d'années elles ont
subi au cours du temps de très
importants bombardement de météorites
qui ont complètement occulté la seule
création de nombreux cratères et même de
véritables bassins et transformation
géologique achement l'évolution
le deuxième grand type de planète du
système solaire sont les planètes
géantes comme saturn ici jupiter leur
atmosphère est agité de mouvement très
violent avec ici sur jupiter devait-elle
cyclone permanents dont la taille est
deux fois celle de la terre et ses
planètes géantes possèdent tous deux des
satellites naturels avec en plus pour
saturn tout un système d'anneaux très
complexe jupiter comme saturn sont
essentiellement constitués
ne possède pas de véritable surface
solide et seulement un noyau central
fait de roche de place elles ont pu
mathieu
enfin le glas de cette jeune est un
agréable lieu de trois uranus neptune et
puis deux constituées principalement
d'hydrogène
le système solaire un monde fascinant
que les hommes
des temps il doit rencontrer aujourd'hui
a tenté de percer les mystères
les éléments du système solaire on peut
choisir de les regarder a priori des
télescopes les écouter à l'aide de
radiotélescopes la première observation
astronomique avec même parc
le bac c'est elle
cet avènement persia mais les années 60
on peut désormais la victoire sur six
ans
m
restait 80 investi si le surdoué jupiter
et de son atmosphère
by km d'une heure puis deux ans plus
tard c'est le survol de l'autre planète
géant du système solaire saturne
doté d'un gain dé principalement extrême
complexité a été révélée par année
l'histoire
animant ce disque de 300 mille
kilomètres de diamètre et deux mois 22
mètres d'épaisseur
non placé pendant 120 jours
des images
vous
puis cinq ans plus tard ce sera pour
voyageurs 2 le survol du radius est en
fait de nous aura prévoir toute la terre
ce coûteux lecture
avec le défi 10 années 90 à les voir se
réaliser
vous en mission d'observation du système
solaire
et plus généralement univers
c'est le télescope spatial hubble
un contrat de deux ans à venir
déclaré
aussi à gauche saturne photographiée par
la droite
puissant
selon l'américain rodgers et enfin à
droite telle qu'on peut la voir plus de
filles de la banlieue de la terre comme
des scots sociale
des explorateurs du système solaire qui
n'ont pas fini de nous étonner
la planète du système solaire qui nous
est la plus familière c'est bien sûr la
planète la terre
qui est à notre connaissance la seule
aujourd'hui à posséder la vie
bien que situé à 150 millions de km du
soleil l'histoire est là
l'exécution de son diocèse à son équipe
trois milliards et demi d'années faisait
régner sur terre un véritable enfer de
dante un monde primitif et violent
puis il y à 500 millions d'années
environ c'est l'apparition sur peur
suit la consommation lente mais
progressive de notre planète
lors de différentes thématiques ont
marqué l'évolution de notre planète
flore et faune se modifie et il y a deux
à trois millions d'années ou dépit du
long terme
c'est l'apparition de la sonatel
et sans ces lettres de connaître
l'origine et la présence sur terre des
coiffures vie des produits
c'est pour les cons
aujourd'hui
les glaciers reprend alors d'énormes
étendue
et eva
le jardin d'éden c'est seulement hier
avec la fonte des glaces et la
modification des reliefs nos climats
d'une planète fragile doit rester sous
haute surveillance avec notamment que le
soleil
face à demander s'il a toujours
mieux connaître le soleil cette étoile
qui régit toute forme de vie sur terre
l' agence spatiale européenne et la nasa
ont imaginé en commun un programme
original une sonde appelée ulysse lancé
en 1990 par la navette spatiale
américaine
à l'origine de cet ambitieux programme
l'idée d'aller pour la première fois
regarder le soleil non plus en deux mais
en trois dimensions pour cela il fallait
faire sentir cette sonde du plan d'aidé
technique c'est à dire
du plan sur lequel évoluent les planètes
autour du soleil permettant à suivre
voix n ont jamais imaginé par l'homme
survoler le soleil
en passant par ces deux pôles
la manoeuvre la plus délicate a eu lieu
en février 1992 elle a consisté à
utiliser jupiter comme une fronde en
faisant passer une liste près de la
planète et de son champ magnétique très
puissant
ulysse un programme international qui
intéresse aujourd'hui 120 chercheurs
appartenant à 44 restitue de tous pays
dans le monde
ainsi accélérée par jupiter la sonde une
fois sorti du plan de l'écliptique
devait atteindre la banlieue du soleil
en 1994
en étudiant de près l'environnement
proche du soleil vi devrait être alors
en mesure de donner une explication
plausible est nouvelle à des phénomènes
physiques encore bien mystérieux
pourquoi des fonds énormes de place
massenet vers ce type de temps à autre
dans l'héliosphère quels mécanismes
physiques régissent les éruptions où les
vents solaires
c'est à ces questions et à bien d'autres
du lys devra tenter de répondre
observez les particules et les champs
magnétiques de régions encore inexploré
comme celle des deux pôles du soleil
c'est bien là toute l'originalité du lys
pour la première fois vera le soleil
dans sa troisième dimension
un fabuleux voyage très chaotique au
milieu des émissions de rayons x de
particules énergétiques de rayon et de
poussière cosmique de bouffées de rayons
gamma et de gaz interstellaires quatre
ans après avoir quitté la terre ulysse
devait atteindre le pôle sud du soleil
en juin 94 et mettre cinq mois pour
traverser sept premières régions
polaires passage à l'équateur du soleil
en février 95 des survols envenime au
nord de notre étoile
septembre 1995 avec à la clé une
meilleure connaissance de notre soleil
et de la formidable énergie d'existence
m soleil en deuil
plus exactement parvenir à maîtriser
sûreté de l'énergie comparables à celles
produites dans le soleil et avoir un
siess disposition de son immunité
d'énergie
dès leur jeu de la fusion
thermonucléaire
les technologies de pointe en cours
d'expérimentation par le commissariat à
l'énergie atomique
au centre d'études de cadarache dans le
sud de la france
l'improbable rejoint leurs atomes cea
contrairement à l'aficion aussi s'est
passé
pour en libérer l'énergie csn
la fusion a réalisé ici va consister à
rapprocher suffisamment près de noyaux
légers 1-2 terium et un de tritium avec
par plusieurs une forme à noyaux bourg
et produisent un site de l'énergie
si le principe est simple les chercher
haut niveau
dans deux ans
de copier la nature
c'est à l'intérieur de ce réacteur de
fusion appelé tokamak torts et supra
pourtant de recréer le processus se
produire
mais le terium ambitionne c'est la
chaleur nécessaire
la vision est bien
place depuis son chalet le thoré
glassman
racine la loi de la chambre déjà le
fossé
c'est vous
notre procédé assez
confinement inertiel reçu
défense la meilleure performance
mondiale
dans seulement
à
imagine européenne a stagné dans
laquelle
à 200 millions
un progrès
deux lieux le jour
les débuts de la water
non seulement je souffre
anthony soleil pour produire de
l'énergie quasi inépuisable un rêve qui
pourrait devenir réalité
la complexité de ces phénomènes et bien
d'autres
aussi d observer toute la clarté dans
une étoile le soleil la plus proche des
étoiles de la tribune
notre soleil serment un site modèle les
astronomes pourrait tenter de chercher
sur d'autres étoiles l'existence comme
sur notre sol de champs magnétiques de
cycle d'activité
attention
quelle est la source d'énergie viable et
voilà seize années lumières de louer des
bleus alors que tout cela les journaux
pourquoi les étoiles de la grande ourse
com
plupart des autres étudiantes
infirmières 22 corps dit stop
pourquoi castor dans la constellation
des gémeaux des pipoles étoiles doubles
mais un système formé de six est là le
groupe et en travers
les géantes rouges les plus grandes des
étoiles sont elles deux étoiles en fin
de vie dévorant tout sur leur passage et
les naines brunes détient de rethel et
secrets de la masse manquante des
poubelles
enfin le tout noir il serait selon la
théorie associé à une étoile à neutrons
après l'explosion nucléaire d'une
extrême violence
un monde binaire les deux objets plus
grand et massif est si proche l'autre
serait physiquement lieu
un système seront extrêmement dur est
donc très chaud dans lequel les deux
heures j'ai ce raid est formé par leurs
jambes l'invitational vous êtes assis le
chemin qui reste à parcourir à la
connaissance pour parvenir à donner une
explication satisfaisante et clair à
tous ces mystères qui régissent la vie
du mouvement et la mort des galaxies qui
nous entourent mais aussi de la nôtre si
proche et pourtant si lointaine
bien des théories ont été émises pour
expliquer la formation de notre système
solaire une action conjuguée de
tourbillon pour des cartes une nébuleuse
cognitif pour kant et la place une
collision entre le soleil et une comète
pour buffon ou plus récemment la
traction du soleil sur de la matière
interstellaire les planètes étant issus
de cette matière de soleil la fabuleuse
aventure d'une étoile en milieu de vie
et dont il nous reste que 5 milliards
d'années pour tenter d'en percer les
sous
en bon